i'm wondering in terms of the the log4j
vulnerability how many federal or if
federal systems have been affected by
that vulnerability
if it was because uh the government
hadn't done the necessary patchwork um
to prevent it from happening and if the
firms that you spoke with today
made any commitments in terms of uh you
know financial assistance or other
assistance to
maintain kind of critical open source
software since this seems to be an issue
that continues to follow up
so first the president signed an
executive order last year that goes to
uh procurement of software by the united
states government and fundamentally
raises the game and we're in the process
of implementing that and actually where
things stand with respect to departments
and agencies of the us government today
as it compared to nearly one year ago
today when the president took office we
are in a much more robust posture and
that's due to the work uh not just of
the interagency but of specific
departments and agencies that have
implemented that executive order in
terms of the the session today i'm not
going to speak on behalf of the
companies in terms of the commitments
they made but it was an incredibly
constructive discussion about ways that
the public sector in the private sector
can work effectively together to ensure
that public sector systems are more
robust and resilient and private sector
systems are more robust and resilient
i'll leave it at that
um and uh we will try to develop along
with the participants in that meeting
and agreed read out so that we're not
betraying any confidences yeah well uh
russia and ukraine secretary clinton
said at the start of the week that he
didn't expect any major breakthroughs
this week but that one positive outcome
could obviously be a de-escalation of
tensions given the current state of play
given everything that you've said what
specifically does that look like from
your view russia de-escalating
uh it would involve them uh reducing the
number of forces that they have deployed
in aggressive postures towards ukraine
that would ultimately be a key part of
de-escalation there are other steps that
russia could take in respect to
de-escalation uh that go far beyond
ukraine as well but in terms of
uh the proximate challenge in and around
the border of ukraine that would be an
important step i would also say one
other thing that i think is very
important that tony you mentioned
secretary blinken's comments at the
beginning of the week he said something
at the end of the last of last week that
i want to underscore which is that our
intelligence community
has
developed information which has now been
downgraded that russia is laying the
groundwork to have the option of
fabricating a pretext for an invasion
including through sabotage activities
and information operations by accusing
ukraine of preparing an imminent attack
against russian forces in eastern
ukraine
we saw this playbook in 2014
they are preparing this playbook again
and and we will have the administration
will have further details on what we see
as this potential laying of a pretext to
share with the press over the course of
the next 24 hours yeah on the flip side
of that and make clear that the us will
respond in the face of russian
aggression but i'm trying to get a sense
of what the u.s would need to see in
order to actually respond would it have
to be tanks and troops crossing the
border or would things like moving
helicopters and tactical weapons be
enough for the us to take steps to
impose sanctions when you say moving
helicopters and tactical weapons you
mean on to the territory of ukraine
our position is quite straightforward if
the russian military
moves across the ukrainian frontier
to seize territory we believe that that
is the further invasion of ukraine and
it will trigger a response from the
united states and the international
community yeah
thank you
i want to ask about your current policy
in this crisis but first if you'll
indulge me i'd like to ask something of
a historical nature first
i assume you'll correct me if i'm wrong
that in preparation for president
biden's first summit with president
putin held in geneva last june
the national security team undertook a
comprehensive review
of the official documentary record
of all the interactions that president
trump had with president putin
you may recall during the trump
presidency we saw reporting to the
effect that mr trump and or his aides
took some steps to
prevent the
maintenance of a full record of those
interactions
without asking you to disclose any
classified information
can you assure us on two points number
one
did your review uncover any evidence of
any effort at any point along the way in
the creation and storage of those
records
to tamper with that process
and number two did your review uncover
any evidence of any impropriety of any
kind or severity on the part of
president trump in his interactions with
president putin
on that question i've got nothing for
you okay it's a current policy then
um
this administration has tried without
success to use sanctions to compel the
military in myanmar to abandon its coup
d'etat
this administration has used sanctions
without success to compel china to
release the concentration camp inmates
in xinjiang the obama administration of
course used sanctions without success to
try to deter a russian annexation of
crimea here you stand again brandishing
the threat of sanctions to try to deter
a russian invasion of ukraine
why shouldn't this be perceived as
clinging to a failed tactic and why
shouldn't president putin assess on that
basis that his adversary is operating
from a position of relative weakness
president putin has indicated that what
he does not want to see
is further nato force posture coming
closer to his border president putin has
indicated that what he does not want to
see is further american
and allied support to ukraine president
putin has indicated that
what he does want to see is the further
strengthening
of russian strategic industries in the
russian economy
we have laid out on all of those metrics
that russia
will suffer costs and consequences in
the event of a further invasion of
ukraine and
he can make his own determination about
what he wants to do but the united
states is going to act we're going to
act with our allies and partners on
those issues in those ways we have the
capacity to do that and we will do that
and president biden has been clear that
that's what we intend to do the actions
work
well so first i would say that if you go
back to
a personal experience i had which was
the negotiation
of the first the interim agreement and
then contributing to the joint
comprehensive plan of action we do
believe that economic pressure on iran
had a meaningful impact on bringing it
to the table and ultimately putting lid
on its nuclear program there are other
instances where sanctions have worked
and of course there are instances across
administrations democrat and republican
alike where sanctions have not achieved
the full result uh and so i'm not going
to stand before you and say sanctions
are a panacea they're a tool that solves
every problem but remember sanctions are
only one part of the way that we and our
allies are talking about how we will
deal with a potential russian invasion
of ukraine we have other tools to bring
to bear as well those tools also bear on
the interests and the security
capacities of the russian federation and
our goal at the end of the day here is
not
to get into an escalatory spiral it is
to find a way forward consistent with
our principles consistent with our
interests and consistent with open
transparent consultation with our allies
uh to pursue diplomacy if that works
great if that doesn't work we're ready
yeah with all of that said is the window
of time closing when it comes to the
fluency on this issue and when you talk
about options that are on the table you
said sanctions is one of the tools what
are the other options presidents have
a
whole host of options and they've always
said when they are met with these types
of situations all options are on the
table are all options on the table for
this moment
well we've been clear
both directly to the russians and we've
actually been clear publicly about some
of the other options and they include
changes in
the forces and capabilities that the
united states and nato
would deploy to eastern flank allies to
reinforce
uh and strengthen the robustness of
allied defense on allied territory we've
made clear that in the event of an
invasion in addition to the support we
are currently providing to the
ukrainians we would dramatically ramp up
that support uh to support their
territorial
territorial integrity and sovereignty
we've also been clear that we are uh
going to work in tandem with allies and
partners not just in europe but in other
parts of the world on export controls
that would have an impact on strategic
industries in russia so those are some
of the extra the additional tools that
we can bring to bear in this context all
of them go to the basic proposition that
the united states is going to look to
strengthen and reinforce our position
and our allies position and to support
the ukrainians in the event of an
invasion
further invasion of ukraine
opportunity for diplomacy is that
closing as i asked earlier
look
it's hard for me to characterize where
things stand on the diplomacy because
we've come through these four days
we need to sit and consult with allies
and partners
wendy sherman is just getting off a
plane she may have gotten off a plane in
the last few hours
we'll take stock of where we are we'll
consult and then we'll determine next
steps the russians will have to do the
same
and all i can tell you is as far as
we're concerned we are ready to move
forward on diplomacy and we are ready to
go down the other path uh and both of
those in my view that question of which
path is one that is facing us now it's
not facing us a year from now or five
years from now it's facing us in the in
the foreseeable future yeah thank you so
much
what happens if nothing happens i mean
if russia doesn't invade ukraine but
keeps like this massive amount of troops
at the border is this something you can
live with in this case would there be
sanctions less sanctions no sanctions at
all
so
we're trying to first of all deter and
prevent a
potentially massive
russian invasion that's step number one
if we end up in a circumstance of the
kind you describe we'll deal with that
as it comes but i'm not going to get
into hypotheticals today in terms of our
reaction i'll just take one more
question
uh to follow up but at this moment are
we in a position where
what
the next step is
reducing the troops of the border when
the borders are reoccurring is this the
next thing that can happen that could
satisfy the us and the allies
what do you mean by the next thing
what what's after the week we've had
what are we expecting that they take of
course we're hoping that they but the
the true the russian troops uh back off
but
is this the only next step possible of
course there's the invasion but
after the entire week of diplomacy well
what i've said all along is that we're
happy to talk we're happy to talk about
our interests and our concerns we're
happy to listen to the russians talk
about their interests and their concerns
but we've also been very clear from the
beginning that to make concrete progress
real tangible progress it has to happen
in an environment of de-escalation so we
will have to see now on the diplomatic
path what comes next we'll have to
determine that first with our friends
and then in engagement with the russians
and
as i stand here today i can't tell you
what the next steps will be and i can
only tell you that um the united states
blind administration our allies and
partners were prepared uh to deal with
whatever comes
the ambiance
in the negotiation today i mean you may
reference to the
pessimists or the different uh
statements we heard but the russians uh
of officials that a more pessimistic and
negative tone
did they have the same tone when they
were face to face with the they were
professional and business-like we
clearly disagreed on things and there
were areas where both sides saw there
was a possibility for progress beyond
that it's hard for me really to
characterize their point of view they
can characterize it for themselves thank
you guys
thank you so much jake you're always
invited
okay um
i know there's a lot going on so we'll
try to get around to everybody i just
have two um
items for all of you at the top
sorry lots of stuff in here
uh in december as a part of the
administration's approach to
strengthening america's supply chains
dress bottlenecks and lower prices for
americans the department of
transportation and the department of
labor announced the biden harris
trucking action plan today to uphold the
30-day commitments made in the trucking
action plan the the department of
transportation and the department of
labor are announcing next steps on
several new initiatives some of them
some of which were mandated by the
infrastructure law to support drivers
improve driver retention while expanding
access to quality driving jobs now and
in the years ahead
these include
expanding registered apprenticeship
programs more than 100 employees and
industry partners all right
everything's okay i think just a
statement may have gone out on the
supreme court ruling that probably is in
your inboxes so that's one note for all
of you um
these include these steps announced
today include expanding registered
apprenticeship programs more than 100
employers and industry partners have
stepped forward to work to expand
registered apprenticeships in the last
30 days this is the gold standard of
training and retaining a skilled
workforce
creating the women of trucking advisory
board mandated to gather input on how to
build a more inclusive and equitable
workplace for women in the trucking
industry and creating a new task force
to investigate predatory trucking
leasing agreements with the department
of labor the consumer finance bureau
protection bureau
and the consumer finance protection
bureau beginning two studies to explore
the issues of truck driver pay and
unpaid detention time and launching the
safe driver apprenticeship pilot an
under pilot program for truck drivers
all of this is an effort to expand the
number of truck drivers we have so we
can move more goods get more goods onto
the shelves lower prices for american
people one more item for all of you
this saturday january 15th is the last
day to sign up for the quality
affordable healthcare coverage on
healthcare.gov a record 14.2 million
people uh have enrolled since the start
of open enrollment on november 1st
on healthcare.gov alone
four out of five consumers are finding
quality coverage for less than ten
dollars per month and a new hhs report
out today found that thanks to the
american rescue plan a majority of
healthcare.gov enrollees are also
receiving subsidies to cut their co-pays
deductibles and other out-of-pocket
spending to be be sure to go to
healthcare.gov anyone listening before
midnight and january 15th and get
covered with that zeke why don't you
kick us off thank you uh my inbox is
usually pretty fast because somebody can
give us that reaction to the uh the
supreme court uh opinions and uh on the
substance of the matter there um how uh
how much of a blow is this to the
administration's plan pandemic response
plan uh to have the employer mandated
part and test you're testing your
vaccination manager
halted and how will that affect the
course of the paper sure uh well i know
there'll be a pr the statement from the
president that should be coming into
your inboxes any moment now um but let
me uh let me give you a quick reaction
first let me start with some good news
uh news that maybe isn't getting enough
attention yet that's our jobs here or my
job here i should say
cms's requirements for healthcare
workers to be vaccinated will save the
lives of patients as well as the lives
of doctors nurses and others who work in
health care settings it will cover 17
million health care workers at 76 000
medical facilities the supreme court
upheld it and we will and uh enforce
that uh the senate uh the the supreme
court's decision on the osha mandate
essentially means that in the pantiness
pandemic it is up to individual
employers to determine whether their
workplaces will be safe for employees
and whether their businesses will be
safe for consumers so president biden
you'll see this in his statement will be
calling on and will continue to call on
businesses to immediately join those
those who have already stepped up
including one third of fortune 100
companies uh to institute vaccination
requirements to protect their workers
customers and communities we have to
keep working together in order uh to uh
get this done to save more lives um i
would note that there are a couple of um
sign good signs in terms of uh without
this um
even even in spite of the ruling that we
would point to one is that 57
according to a navigator poll of
american support vaccine requirements
according to a wills tower watson's
report a survey of 534 u.s employers a
majority 57 percent of respondents have
or will require their employees to get
vaccinated against cobit 19. why
because nearly uh because employees want
to feel safe in the workplace
because they want to incentivize workers
to come back to the workplace and
because they've seen large companies
across the country implement this and
see how effective it is
another adjacent covert topic the
president announced today that
he's going to announce next week that
he's going to be discovering making free
high quality classes available to
americans um there's this the new
testament website which is launching
next uh
website why is it you know middle of
january right now when a million
americans are testing positive recovery
today roughly
why is the president taking these steps
now why didn't you take these three
months ago well let me let me first say
that what the president what we've been
working to implement is building on the
steps we've taken over the last six
months and more remember when the
president took office there were zero or
one
approved testing at home testing
option on the market now there are nine
we needed to expand the market capacity
the president used the defense
production act three billion dollars
invested to expand that market the
reason he was able to announce the
purchase of or the plan to purchase an
additional 500 million beyond the 500
million we already announced is because
of the expansion of the market and just
since last summer leading up to december
we had quadrupled the size of the market
so if you look at the the comparison
right now we're doing almost 12 million
tests a day in this country we were
doing under 2 million tests a day a year
ago there's about 300 million tests that
are happening in this country every
single day in part because there's 20
000 sites because there are federal
sites now across the country new ones we
announce every day because we've sent 50
million tests to community health
centers so all of this is an effort to
build on that and make sure that that
capacity and need and we're meeting the
unprecedented demand for tests these are
steps of the presentation now because
there's an unmet need he
presumably could have done the exact
same thing three months ago when
maybe it would be an effect now when the
need is obviously greater than that
the system has capacity to deliver
well i would say zeke that again because
of the steps we've taken we're able to
uh there's 300 million tests that are
happening in this country every single
month and that is enormous progress
we're not starting from zero that is my
point so this is building on that but in
terms of the number of tests available
in the market and the expansion of the
market remember a number of them were
just approved at the end of october or
beginning of november the using the
defense production act means we needed
to ensure there's manufacturing capacity
and build on that this has all been a
building process and we're continuing to
expand and build from here i would also
note that in recent polls uh despite
some of the conversations we have in
here it's less than 10 percent of the
american public that can't find a test
uh we have expanded capacity and you're
seeing the impact of that across the
country
lastly on the on the voting push
we've heard a lot from the president uh
talking about uh republican uh
controlled states taking actions to
limit uh access to the polls i wonder if
the election laws we have different
states and jurisdictions um has the
president ever reached out to democratic
states and you know you know it's like
new york that don't have you know early
in-person voting or new jersey or
delaware that have some different laws
that exist you know maybe down south and
call down and encourage them to loosen
their voting laws to bring them in line
with some of the restrictions
objectively being rolled back right now
well i think look i think the
president's view on expanding access to
voting whether it's the expansion of
early voting or the number of mail and
voting boxes uh steps we know works to
increase uh the participation of people
in the process is something it's very
well known that he purchased that he
viewed that he strongly supports the dnc
typically does a lot of the outreach on
election implementation but i don't
think it's a secret where the president
stands and certainly you heard him say
that earlier this week and convey it
again on capitol hill today
give us a few details of what the back
and forth was like for the president and
the senators at the line she sounded
pretty frustrated when he came out
i i think he sounded passionate that's
what i saw and heard um look i think the
president conveyed directly to the
caucus what many people heard him say
across the country a couple of days ago
that now we face a system a systematic
effort to dismantle democracy not just
voter suppression but subversion you
heard him say that when he came out
and spoke to uh spoke after he left the
meeting he conveyed that this is a
historic chance to save our democracy
need to protect the fundamental form of
american government and his view is this
absolutely be bipartisan i know we've
talked a bit about the history of uh
senator mcconnell's support multiple
times over writing about in his book for
voting rights in the past there are 16
republicans serving now who supported
voting rights in the past
even as the president has said strom
thurman back did back in in the 80s
obviously he's not serving today but
just as an example um so that's part of
the point he made uh also i think it's
important for everybody to understand
that his view is that he would put his
record of standing up uh for the history
of the senate the institution of the
senate uh the rules of the senate up
against anyone's democrat republican
anyone serving today and before then but
his view is that it's it's a time there
are times in history now is one of them
where you can't allow the protection of
processed to get in the way of
protecting people's fundamental rights
and that is also an argument that he
made today to the caucus what happens
now with the legislation
well leader schumer has obviously
conveyed what his plan and his path
forward is
and i think members are going to have an
opportunity to vote and decide and
determine uh what side of history they
want to be on
go ahead thanks jen
did some of her cinema's remarks on the
floor today come as a surprise to
president biden or had she conveyed them
in private to the president or to the
white house i'm not going to get into
private conversations with any senator
including senator cinema
can you tell us the last time they spoke
i'm not going to get into more details
about private conversations
during his first press conference last
march the president was asked if there
was anything he could do to protect
voting rights outside of passing
legislation at the time he said yes
i don't want to reveal my strategy
now can you tell us whether the white
house has identified any more executive
actions that the president can and plans
to take
well uh first i would say the president
did sign a historic executive order
early on in his presidency also since
that period of time i believe the
department of justice has doubled their
funding and support for uh protection of
voting rights in states obviously the
the uh he has spoken about this issue
very vocally in recent months since that
period of time multiple times as well
the vice president has been leading this
effort to gather support across the
country and we're of course going to
continue to look for ways to protect
people's fundamental rights the next
step is of course these votes in the
senate
i have a question about a video that
iran's supreme leader posted on his
website
that appears to show a robot
conducting a drone strike killing the
former president at his mar-a-lago golf
club
is the intelligence community assessing
this threat
and working with former president trump
um to
offer protection of any kind
i'm not going to speak to the work of
our intelligence community obviously uh
the uh the kind of uh rhetoric or video
uh from the supreme leader is something
that uh we've seen um you know offensive
uh offensive rhetoric and behavior in
the past um but i'm not gonna speak to
more specifics of internal discussions
are you aware of the video i don't have
any more details on it okay um and then
one more for a colleague who's not here
um the embassy in baghdad the u.s
embassy just tweeted about an attack
that happened there do you have any
details or any response i don't this may
have just recently happened i don't have
any more details but we can venture to
get you something after the briefing
back on the supreme court's decision
more than 80 million people would have
been affected by this uh vaccine and
testing mandate so what kind of impact
does this decision have on the broader
effort just to get kobe under control
well i i think we're already looking at
this point in time of
more than 71 percent of people have had
both shots uh that to make them fully
protected obviously we're encouraging
people of course to get boosted more
than 80 83 i believe at this point have
had their first shot we're going to
continue to work full speed at doing
that obviously this was a step that we
announced and we had every intention of
implementing because we knew that it was
the point where putting in place
requirements in the workplace would help
get more people vaccinated the good news
is that a number of companies have
already decided to do that and do that
successfully and the work and the effort
is really going to be on their shoulder
so really it's going to depend on how
effective that is your message to
employees and workers who may see this
decision and be concerned about what
comes next for them
uh our message is that we're going to
continue to work with
employers across the country and
continue to convey very clearly what the
benefit of
vaccine or testing requirements would be
on workplaces both as many companies
struggle to fill their workplaces
struggle to bring people back to the
workplace people who are concerned about
their safety that this is an effective
measure and there are many models across
the country to implement it
go ahead thanks jen should we expect the
administration to try to issue a more
targeted mandate following the supreme
court ruling today i don't have any
additional uh predictions of next steps
here but are you going to
try this again or is are you accepting
what the supreme court decided again
they just decided any legal action i'd
obviously defer to the department of
justice but
at this point in time we are encouraging
private sector companies to do is to
take steps that have effectively worked
around the country uh that many the vast
majority of employers have indicated
they have the intention to do
okay and when it comes to the lunch that
happened today
senator cinema before the president got
up there reiterated that she does not
want to change the 60 vote threshold
senator manchin just said now in a
statement that he does not want to
change that has the president accepted
that he cannot sway them when it comes
to changing the filibuster and creating
an exception i think we're going to keep
fighting till the votes are had
but they have said today that they are
not changing their positions despite an
appeal directly from the president and
the president spoke to this after look
his job is to take on tough challenges
to speak out for what's right and he
thinks making changes to the rules in
order to get voting rights passed and
protect people's fundamental rights is
right we'll leave it to leader schumer
on what the next steps are and what the
process is from here but we are going to
keep having meetings keep having calls
and that will be what the president's uh
focus will be
what was his response to seeing senator
sinema come out just a few minutes
before he got up there
which she knew what he was coming to
talk about and say that she did not
support it i think the president was
most focused on speaking directly to the
caucus not on her comments
what is the president's i guess the
administration's backup plan when it
comes to
voting rights and getting legislation
passed is there a backup plan
as you heard the president say when he
came out of the caucus meeting uh we're
going to keep at it we're going to stay
at it uh the president's
what people that means caitlyn that any
piece of legislation that's ever passed
that's hard that's difficult goes
through it goes through some ups and
downs and goes through some challenges
that doesn't mean you give up that's not
what leadership is leadership is
continuing to fight for what's right
continuing to fight to get something
done that means sometimes it fails we
don't know what will happen next that
means sometimes uh there are or are gaps
between when you get to move forward
we're going to have to determine what
the next steps are but in the meantime
the president is going to continue to
make calls he's going to continue to
engage with his colleagues uh and that's
where his focus is on at this point in
time
go ahead thank you
i have a couple specific ones but i
wanted to kind of follow on that um
if you're determining next steps
i mean frankly things just seem like
they're going pretty poorly right now
for the white house
you know buildback bettors
being blocked voting rights being
blocked
diplomatic talks russia
doesn't seem to have brought us back
from the rank the brink of war
inflation's at a 40-year high the virus
is setting records for infection so
as we kind of hit this one-year period
and a period where
everything seems like it's in pretty
rough shape or nearly everything
which is not an invitation i guess to
list off um
some other things uh
i i'm i'm wondering at what point do you
take stock and say that things need to
change internally whether it's
your outreach for the hill whether it's
the leadership within the white house
you seem to be stagnated on an
incredible number of fronts right now
well let me give you a little bit of a
different take on this uh more than 200
million people are vaccinated we've had
a record job growth record low
unemployment rates
historically in this country over the
last year we've rebuilt our alliances
and our relationships around the world
and right now as it relates to russia as
you heard our national security advisor
convey we're working with partners
around the world to convey very clearly
it's up to them to make a choice about
what's next we're not going to make that
on their behalf
it's up to them to determine if they're
going to be crippling economic sanctions
or not or
if they decide to move forward but we
also recognize when you have a a small
margin and threshold in the senate it's
very difficult to get things done and to
get legislation passed and the fact that
the president under his leadership got
the american rescue plan passed a
bipartisan infrastructure bill with 19
votes in the senate about six votes in
the house uh the fact that we are still
continuing to to work with members to
determine the path forward on bill beck
better that we have the vast majority of
democrats in the senate supporting
voting rights that's a path forward for
us and our effort is to do hard things
try hard things and keep at it so we
just don't see it through the same prism
so the senses things are going well
there's no need for change right now i
think that uh having worked in a white
house before
you do hard things in white houses
you have every challenge at your at your
feet laid out your feet whether it's
global or domestically
and we could certainly propose
legislation to see if people
support bunny rabbits and ice cream but
that wouldn't be very rewarding to the
american people so the president's view
is we're going to keep pushing for hard
things and we're going to keep pushing
the boulders up the hill to get it done
the president announced the distribution
of high quality masks earlier today
that's been kind of a vague and
undefined phrase i understand well
fitting like what that literally means
but in terms of the math that you're
trying to procure do you have a sense of
the 1095s kn95s
in that universe or is that just we're
not quite there we'll have more uh i
expect in the coming days on that and uh
but right now just so people understand
that the back story here the history i
should say is we have distributed more
than 30 million uh mass to food banks
and community health centers states have
been doing that as well
we have a stockpile of 700 million high
quality masks in the government and they
are also widely available across the
country so what we're talking about here
is making high quality masks as you know
available to the american people for
free there are a lot of ranges of high
quality masks i think we'll have more
details on that and what that looks like
next week
uh i know you're limited a little bit
about what you can say about politics
from the podium but the rnc said today
that
they would ask their candidates not to
participate in debates held by the
commission that has done it for the last
few decades
do you or the president have any
reaction to
that move by the rnc
well the the president has participated
in many debates uh over the course of
his career um
and uh believes they play a role in
allowing the american people to hear
from candidates and where they stand
so i think it's more oppose a question
best pose to the rnc on what they're so
afraid of participating
that was
planning to run for re-election at least
he said and um
would he would he participate in the
debate outside of the commission uh
yeah i would point you to the dnc for
that and any more specifics go ahead the
president when he spoke to reporters
after the senate launch today he spoke
about the voting rights push in the past
tense he said we missed this time
what then is the political value in
moving forward with these show votes
given that the president effectively has
acknowledged that this process has ended
and risk potentially shining a light on
democratic divisions
well i think uh you all can count who's
for and against each vote whether it's
changes to the uh to the senate rules or
uh supporting these these voting bills
themselves and i think it's very uh
people publicly know where senators
stand at this point in time i will leave
it to we will leave it to and we'll work
lot in lockstep with him leader schumer
to determine what this next steps are
here and i know he's spoken a bit to
that but ultimately um this is about
continuing to press uh to move forward
on the protection of voting rights and
to use it as a moment to elevate this
issue as an important issue for people
across the country
and of course any senator is going to be
put in the position of determining what
side of history they're going to stand
on and that's i guess the purpose of a
vote the president also spoke about
voter subversion when he spoke to
reporters but neither the freedom to
vote act nor the john lewis voting
rights act
deal with subversion i focus more on
suppression
would the president want to see
democrats if this process does move
forward in the future
address
uh
laws in in these 19 states some of which
would potentially allow for the
overturning of a free and fair election
well the john lewis voting rights act um
actually in section 112 actually makes
it illegal for state officials to
willfully fair or fail or refuse to
certify the aggregate tabulations of
votes or certify the election of the
candidates receiving sufficient such
votes to be elected to office that is
obviously addressing a root problem
we're seeing in laws in many states
across the country and what these laws
are meant to do is provide some
fundamental baselines for protections
for voters and that's an important part
of doing it obviously there's more you
will continue to build from there but
that's an important component i think
that sometimes everyone isn't always
aware of in the john lewis voting rights
act
oh good one unrelated question about the
u.s postal service yesterday
the board of governors
elected a new chairman uh someone who
has expressed support for postmaster
general lewis to joy who as you know is
at a very controversial tenure what's
what's the white house position on the
persistent delivery delays that the
postal service seems to be experiencing
at least anecdotally and uh dejoy's
current place is postmaster general does
he deserve to have that role you know i
love anecdotal data i will tell you that
going back to the holidays uh 97 or 98
of packages from the postal service were
delivered on time so there may be
anecdotes from that one or two percent
but those are that's actual data
okay but 98 798 across the country uh we
have expressed concerns in the past
about delay's leadership that i've
delayed sorry it's a joy that was a
little slip there dejoy's leadership um
in the past that has not changed i will
say though um and i know this has been
raised i'm just going to use it as an
opportunity to address it that that many
members of the postal service including
leadership has expressed a confidence
and an interest in playing the role in
delivering tests to people across the
country and their confidence in doing
exactly that
so we take them at their word and uh
certainly we're encouraged by the data
we saw from december
go ahead oh april let me first say 25
years uh covering the white house that's
pretty significant
i don't have a song for this but just
congratulations
i mean i'm a terrible singer so we don't
want that anyway go ahead
give me an interview with president
on the record right right um
on another issue jen um the issue of
policing as you're working on voting
rights you understand simultaneously
you're working diligently on this
executive order to bring more teeth into
uh protections
for people americans particularly
minorities who are
dying at the hands of
policing
what is different
with this
executive order versus
what could have happened on capitol hill
we understand laws have more teeth but i
understand that you guys are working to
bring more teeth into these executive
orders talk to me about that
it's a great question april and as you
know from covering this closely we were
kind of waiting on any executive orders
um out of the out of uh deference to the
negotiations that were happening in a
bipartisan manner and of course we
believe that
the ability especially in a bipartisan
way when possible to move forward on
legislation makes it permanent right um
and that is not the case of course uh
with executive orders in terms of the
specific details there are they are
under discussion i just don't have
anything i can outline for you at this
moment because there's an internal
policy discussion i understand there's a
sense of urgency on it i was told
from one source it was days and then
others said it could be weeks but it's
happening soon why the sense of urgency
right now especially when you're dealing
with voting rights trying to figure that
out as well
you know i think there's a recognition
and a commitment uh by the president to
deliver on what he promised and of
course we're very supportive of the
efforts uh to negotiate police reform on
a bipartisan level obviously that didn't
move forward as we would have hoped um
and so uh there's there's a there's a
legal policy substantive process that
has to go through in the consideration
of executive orders that's ongoing it is
hard to predict the timing of that so i
don't want to do that from here but it's
a it's a it's a reflection of the
president's commitment to delivering on
his promise question um
when candidate for president-elect i
guess you would say uh joe biden was
building his cabinet he specifically
singled out martial fudge for her work
and the fact that she was one of the
presidents of delta sigma theta sorority
incorporated that is having its founders
day he talked about the great work that
the sorority does um what does he have
for the delta sorority delta sigma theta
sorority incorporated um today as they
celebrate founders since he knows about
them so well of course um well the
president wishes the women of delta
sigma theta sorority incorporated a
happy 109th founder's day and many more
years of academic excellence and service
to those uh who are members um the
president has been very vocal of his
support as you noted april for delta
sigma theta and all divine nine
sororities and fraternities in october
vice president harris hosted a historic
meeting of the divine nine councils of
council of presidents at the white house
which included immediate past president
uh beverly smith and we're incredibly
grateful to the work he is uh delta
sigma theta has done to uplift
communities across the world especially
the hard work of former national
president and current hud secretary
marcia fudge and the women of delta
sigma theta who work on behalf of the
american people in the biden harris
administration each and every day which
i hear there are a few go ahead
uh also a one-way one-year kind of
question
when you listen to the president's
inauguration address you hear the words
unity you hear
better angels of america we didn't hear
these words in his speeches at the
capitol or in georgia does it mean that
he has changed his state of mind and
does it think that america can't be
unified anymore
no actually quite the contrary and the
president believes that protecting
people's fundamental rights to vote and
participate in the process whether
you're a democrat a republican an
independent whatever party
you are a member of
that that is not a partisan issue
it should be a unifying issue and and
that is why he reflected when he went to
the caucus today on the fact that there
are 16 republicans who have supported
voting rights in the past because it is
not been historically uh a uh a partisan
issue and he's not prejudging who people
support he is trying to protect people's
ability to participate in the process
if i may um with the congress as it is
with the supreme court as it is uh
what's the way forward for the rest of
the mandate is it more executive orders
is it smaller steps greater than you
know big transformative reforms what's
you know what's the idea well that's a
big question um but i would say i would
say that um
the president has had we we feel we've
had a lot of success over the past year
um getting the economy back on stronger
footing um
getting 200 million americans vaccinated
getting a bipartisan infrastructure bill
passed rebuilding our relationships in
the world and america standing in the
world and what we want to do now is
build on that in year two that means
continuing to press to get voting rights
done to get bill back better done
there are
to get chips funding passed so we can
ensure that manufacturing happens in the
united states so of course there's still
big bold pieces of the president's
agenda he wants to get done and he's
going to keep fighting for it it is also
true that it is challenging to move
things forward with such a small margin
uh in uh in congress and he is very well
aware of that we've been living it for
almost a year now
go ahead
and test some questions on a couple from
about cool colleagues who sure be here
the president mentioned the other 500
million tests
can you give us any sense on timeline
when you're looking at contracts when
you're looking at delivery when people
will actually
end up seeing them after they see this
first half billion sure so um i had said
earlier this week that we were looking
to finalize our uh contracts for the
first 500 million within the two weeks i
can give you an update that now we're at
the point where we've procured about 380
million
of those tests and we're going to
continue to build from there so the plan
is to um you know we feel we're making
very strong progress of course and after
we conclude this phase we'll begin
awarding contracts for today's
announcement we'll continue to proceed
from there
a
we may be able to as as we kind of
proceed in the process as we have done
with the first 500 million but i don't
have a specific update yet at this point
in time just a status update in the
first 500 million and obviously when we
uh make when we conclude this phase
we'll move to the next 500 million
mentioned earlier in the briefing that
less than 10
of the population is now having trouble
finding a test and it kind of said there
was a recent poll i'm happy to tweet it
after the briefing if you'd like to make
it available to all of you i think it
was a you got full we still see we know
how much you love anecdotal data but
people talking about the long waits
people talking about cvs etc etc
the president made it a point to say
testing has gotten so much better today
but
that would be pretty stark if it's now
one in ten americans claiming that
they're i said a recent poll uh which i
think is just important to know because
um obviously what we we've been doing to
date and where we are at this point in
time is 300 million tests uh every
single month that is a lot of tests and
sometimes you would think that no one is
able to get a test and no one is being
tested when nearly 12 million people are
being tested every day at the same time
as i have said as the president has said
we want to do more and we are continuing
to do more that's why we're running this
expedited process to procure more tests
to ensure they're free they're
accessible and they're available to
people across the country
oh go ahead radio pool colleagues okay
if you will uh the fba ground stop
earlier this week yeah on the heels of
the north korean missile test can you
give us an idea
what information you all have about that
and
is there a fear that these
north korean tests may actually pose
some type of danger or issue for u.s
civil aviation i believe the faa has
spoken to this and uh taken kind of a
look back at what happened i think it
was a 15 minute ground stop and they
have reflected on the procedures that
happened and taken a look for them
moving forward i would note that uh our
national security and most importantly
are defense officials across the country
after those tests conveyed that no
officials were at risk so i'd really
point you to the faa as they assess uh
that uh that decision or last week or
earlier this week sorry yeah go ahead
well uh
a committee to protect journalists
report
questioning saying freedom advocates are
concerned with your administration in
terms of access to the president for
reporters timely responses
you
assange restrictions on access to the
media uh at the southern border limited
help for afghan journalists can you give
us a comment from your perspective on on
how you see those things playing out and
what some of these criticisms are well i
haven't read the report but well i would
say broadly speaking that uh when i
spoke with the president about this job
i mean one of our one of the things he
conveyed to me very clearly was
resetting the tone with the media uh was
a big priority for him and ensuring that
uh there was a respect even when there's
a point of contention or a difficult
conversation or back and forth that that
is part of democracy but our objective
is to uh has been to um reinstill
normalcy and engagement with reporters
whether we agree or disagree uh whether
there is a partisan tilt to an outlet or
not and i think we have conducted
ourselves accordingly and always we're
working to continue to be responsive i
would say i i would say two inquiries of
probably tens of thousands if not more
does not to me sound like a data point
but i will look closer at the report the
other thing i would say is that um you
know the president has taken questions
at about 200 on about 250 occasions over
the past year if you average about three
questions per time that's about 750
questions he's taken that does not
include the formal press conference he
did in march other press conferences
he's done that's about three so let's
say a thousand just to be generous there
that's about three questions a day i
think the american people have seen him
out there answering questions he will
continue to be that's an important part
of his engagement with the press and the
public and that will be a part of how we
continue to conduct ourselves go ahead
james
thank you very much jim
thank you
i want to ask one on the economy and one
on the pandemic
sure
uh on the economy in yesterday's
briefing with mr diese and in today's
briefing
you have both cited um economic metrics
uh that showed great progress across
2021
from the unemployment rate
uh to job creation to a rise in real
household income and when citing the
progress in those areas both you and mr
dees
attributed
that progress to specific administration
policies
and legislative initiatives
yet when it came to uh the highest
inflation in 40 years
both you and mr deese attributed this to
a variety of external factors
from the pandemic to supply chain
constraints to inaction by the congress
on bill back better
so
to be clear
for the american people in this midterm
year who are going to be assessing the
performance of the president and his
party
where specifically inflation is
concerned does the buck stop with the
president
well i i would say james first that the
president has spoken to the fact that
costs for americans and the squeeze it
puts on americans is a top concern for
him and i think brian diese also
conveyed that yesterday and that's why
he put in place a supply chain task
force why we've prioritized taking steps
including having a port czar including
ensuring there are more truckers on the
roads to ensure there are more goods
moving and more goods on the shelves and
we've made a lot of progress in that
regard of course that's his
responsibility and the responsibility of
the economic team i also think it's
notable that if you go back to earlier
this year there were not the projections
of the economic growth we have seen or
the decrease in the unemployment rate we
have seen and that is in part not just
according to us but many outside
economists to the
bills that have passed some of them
bipartisan uh in uh and the work of this
administration to get the economy up and
going again and address covet so your
answer is yes he owns the job creation
he owns the low unemployment rate and he
also owns inflation correct i think any
president should own everything
happening in the country and the
president certainly sees it that way
the president's remarks this morning
included yet another exhortation to the
unvaccinated population to get
vaccinated
he has since assuming office made
dozens and dozens perhaps hundreds of
these kinds of appeals to that
particular population
do you have any evidence
indeed do you have any sound basis
for determining at all
whether he is having any success
in
urging that population to do as he
counsels
we do
if you go back to december of 2020
just over 30 percent maybe 35 percent of
people in this country
was open to getting vaccinated now we're
at the point where more than 80 percent
of the country has gotten at least one
dose what the president also recognizes
is that he's not always the most
effective messenger everybody in the
country is not looking for him to tell
them what to do he certainly knows that
what's most important here is for people
hearing from
local leaders
pediatricians in some cases doctors
people who have different political
beliefs out there uh conveying clear
accurate information about the
effectiveness of these vaccines we think
all of that has had an impact and a lot
of that is stuff that we've implemented
35 of the american population
uh was willing to get vaccinated a year
ago i can give you the data i'm happy to
give that to you after the briefing it
was a public public poll
go ahead thank you john i have two
questions one in haiti the other one on
canada the first one in haiti yesterday
was the 12th anniversary of the terrible
earthquake of 2010.
um
the effects are still being felt over
there uh how has the uh administration
or has the admission followed up on the
uh deport
the migrants that were deported last
fall back the thousands of them that
were that were reported deported over
there
related to the earthquake related to the
earthquake but considering the situation
over there 12 years later
what kind of follow-up has been done
with the migrants that were sent back
last fall well we have a very large
presence on the ground a diplomatic
presence on the ground in haiti and that
has continued to be the case we are also
the one of the largest if not the
largest provider of humanitarian
assistance uh to haiti through ngos and
many outside groups uh in order to
provide assistance for the range of
challenges that uh people in haiti have
gone through from
earthquakes or natural disasters to
obviously the challenge the challenge of
the uh that the assassination of their
leader that happened this past summer so
we will continue to be providers of
humanitarian assistance our diplomatic
presence there is on the ground uh and
working closely with trusted leaders in
the region in the country and and we
will we remain committed to that
the americans on the ground the
officials on the ground haven't been in
contact with the haitians who've been
deported from texas for instance last
fall
well i i again i would say we have a
diplomatic presence on the ground that's
in touch with a range of haitians who
either have been sent back or who need
help and assistance and we work closely
with local authorities to make sure that
the humanitarian assistance is getting
exactly to the people who need it canada
jen i just want to check something with
you uh considering the
the multiple recent trade setbacks uh
with the us uh yeah the the
uh conservative leader in canada this
week uh claimed that uh the u.s canada
relationship is at its lowest point in
decades
uh how do you see this
uh we we don't see it that way um we
view canada as an important neighbor an
important partner a country we are
aligned on and many democratic values uh
we work with on a range of issues facing
the global community uh and that is
certainly the view of our government
here frustration towards for instance
the fact that the buy america
measures are still um imposed actually
more strictly under this administration
we are certainly familiar with the
frustrations of some leaders who were
who have been outspoken about it and
spoke to it when they were here and i
would just reiterate that our objective
here is to make um to make electric
vehicles specifically more accessible to
americans uh to lower the cost here for
americans and that is why the president
pushed so hard for those provisions but
we see canada continue to see canada as
an important partner in the world go
ahead on the president's first
anniversary in office what does he
regard as his single most important
achievement and does he acknowledge that
any mistakes have been made and if so
what's the biggest mistake
uh well i would say first that um
you know the president is very proud of
the progress we've made in getting 200
million americans vaccinated very proud
of the work we have done to
cut the childhood poverty by 40 percent
uh to help americans who needed a little
extra help get by through a challenging
economic time of the work we did to get
a bipartisan infrastructure bill passed
and to rebuild our place in the world
there are many others i think uh
confirming uh nominating confirming uh
historic judges
across the board uh ensuring that our
administration up and down uh the ranks
looks like america uh and i could go on
from there fighting to take steps on
climate in a historic manner uh that has
been more than any administration in the
past uh in terms of uh in terms of what
we look back uh you know i'm not going
to speculate on that from here i will
let the president speak to that the next
time you all see him did he
underestimate donald trump's continued
grip on the republican party and how
difficult that would make it to work
across the isle and unite the nation
you know i will tell you that uh hearing
kevin mccarthy talk today for an example
and seeing what he said on january 21st
last year is a pretty stark reminder of
uh how uh how much uh sway the former
president has over members of his party
i think that's disappointing for
everybody not just people who work here
go ahead thank you jen
i wanted to ask a question from some
colleagues who couldn't be here sure and
then and then before i get to that i
wanted to follow up on a question that
justin asked sure um
the president was in the senate for 36
years yeah
we're at a point where his legislative
agenda on buildback better and voting
rights act has hit major roadblocks
is there some introspection that his
approach to the senate is not working
and is he are there changes that he's
making to his approach to the senate
given his experience there
well i would also point to his
experience leading him to stay focused
and committed to the bipartisan
infrastructure bill something that many
said could never happen and when it was
voted on 19 republicans voted for it he
leaned on his experience in the senate
to get that done he leaned on his
experience in the senate to get the
american rescue plan done and passed
into law and he will continue to lean on
ascent on his experience in the senate
and as for as a former vice president to
press for voting rights legislation to
press for buildback better and getting
those pieces of legislation done so i
would say uh you know the successes we
had in the past year and that he had
despite the fact that there was a slim
margin uh are actually uh i mean i guess
unbiased but pretty impressive given the
margin we had in the senate and the
challenges we had up against us
given that he's ending his first year
underwater um in the polls americans
uh more americans disapprove of his uh
job in office and improve his job in
office what is he planning to do
differently and approach the job in the
second year that
shows that he's listening to that
disapproval well i think what you see in
most of these polls is a real uh
frustration and exhaustion with covet
and the fact that it is not uh over uh
we we share that we understand that
people are fatigued across the country
it's impacting how they live how they
work
their worries about their kids their
ability to experience joyful things in
life like concerts and going to
restaurants and seeing friends we
understand that
the president knows that the best most
important step he can take is to uh
continue to fight to get the pandemic
under control uh and also to lower costs
for americans across the country uh so i
would say it's a continuation of the
fights that he built a great deal of a
base for over the course of the last
year
i think that the disapproval rates are a
reflection of the way he's approached
the job
again i would point you to what most
data shows you which is a frustration
about covid uh and prices and and he
believes and he's believed from the
beginning that addressing covet in the
economy are number two one two three
four issues and uh that continues to be
the case today
our colleagues couldn't be here um
do biden and putin have plans to meet
in the future
i don't have anything to predict for you
on that front uh as jake uh mentioned uh
we're just of course concluding the
third round of talks uh people are gonna
go back to their capitals they're going
to discuss and assess and see where
things stand so in terms of next steps
we'll have to see we'll know more over
the coming days
is there a deadline for moscow at the
escalate in ukraine
again i i'm not going to set any
deadlines here ultimately the choice is
really up to them are they going to
proceed in uh in invading ukraine if so
they're going to be severe consequences
and economic impacts that will be
devastating to the economy they're long
far beyond what happened in 2014 if
that's a choice they want to make and
they think that's to their advantage
that's a choice
they they only have the only they have
the power to make that
thanks everyone
you